[Music]
[Music]
this high school comedy spoke about a
number of issues mainly cultural
appropriation year before it was the
buzzword is today it's like every time
we get some hear y'all come trying to
steal it pin some blondes hair on it you
calling it something different it also
showed a group of black teenagers
refusing a handout in their competition
here I got my dad's company responsible
stead looking into their own community
for financial support we don't need you
and beating the competition in the
process they're just going to say you
know captain's a captain that I
respected to ask about their
you guys were good thanks you were
better
we were huh
okay so the movie isn't perfect
cool outfit slam it slam it but it was
one of the first major Hollywood films
by depicted an interracial couple from
the viewpoint of the black director and
allow a young Kerry Washington a rare
opportunity to critique that
relationship is the big damn deal it's
me and him not us and other people black
people black women and here you come
white so you gotta be right and you take
a few decent men we have left after jail
drugs and drive by that is what Nikki
meant about you up in our world there's
only one world chanel that is what they
teach you we know different
[Music]
this slasher series was always made fun
of common form would be element and also
played them to them peepal Jada
pinkett-smith and Omar Eva's characters
drag war movies treatments of black
characters the dumbass white movie about
some dumbass white girls getting a white
asses cut the [ __ ] you get your PhD in
black cinema sister soldier forward they
die in the first five minutes
[Music]
but the film's other black characters
call out things that they're white leads
aren't Moke enough to see brothers don't
last long in situations like this stupid
people go back ok smart people here in
Disney's billion-dollar box office hit
is basically a critique against
discrimination its depiction of predator
and prey stereotypes and police
profiling share strong similarities to
the human world all we know is that they
are all members of the predator family
they are often the kinds of kids that
are called super predators it may have
something to do with biology no
conscience no empathy we can talk about
why they ended up that way but first we
have to bring them to heel clearly
there's a biological component these
predators may be reverting back to their
primitive savage ways are you serious
egg stop it you're not like them oh
there's a them now you know what I mean
you're not that kind of predator
Spike Lee served as executive producer
of this cohort classic which is cleared
during the opening segment which shows a
political activist being beaten and
killed by police I said I've got nothing
against good cop but I will see lowlife
scum like you run out of the department
the film came out just three years after
footage of Rodney King being brutalized
by police caused five days of riots in
Los Angeles in another scene a racist
politician jhooth Mecca is causing
concern by running for governor beyond
the obvious concern that the black and
Jewish communities share of the kandacy
a one-time plan member dukkha Mecca
there's clear similarities to former Ku
Klux Klan member David Duke who from
1989 to 1992 was a Louisiana State
Representative it's still an act of
white supremacist to this day
you